girl meets world made audiences laugh
with colorful humor for all ages we were
surprised at how many adults we found in
this kids show we discovered 15
hilarious adult jokes that kids probably
missed you're not going to believe what
they got away with at number one if you
like Girl Meets World don't forget to
subscribe so the things and give this
video a thumbs up and now here are 15
funniest little jokes in Girl Meets
World 48 pounds of nasty in the episode
titled Girl Meets Maya's mother the
girls are in art class trying to draw a
bowl of fruit
Farkle walks in wearing a bathrobe and
asked them why they want to draw fruit
when they can draw as he puts it 48
pounds of nasty he flings off his robe
to reveal a long old-timey bathing suit
that covers most of his skinny pubescent
body seriously even we got uncomfortable
we thought he was going to show us his
never mind that's a pretty racy joke for
a teen show and what exactly does he
mean when he says 48 pounds of nasty
it's clear they're making a scrawny
teenage boy joke but the nasty part
there is nothing nasty about this kid
his confidence is admirably though keep
flexing those guns my man maybe one day
a couple of manly bums will appear on
those adorable twigs mom and dad need a
little bedroom action on Topanga and
Cory's anniversary Reilly's little
brother Auggie is not very happy about
being left at home with a babysitter
while his parents at the town for a date
night Topanga tries to explain that
their parents haven't been on a date in
a while
Cory chimes in with an exact amount of
time it's been since their last date he
says it's been three weeks and four days
then he waggles his eyebrows at her
which leaves the impression that he's
not just talking about a date we're
thinking it's been a few weeks since
their last bedroom Olympics session
hopefully this joke flew over the heads
of young viewers no kid likes to think
of their parents having a private
wrestling match on the bed
ooh that's enough to traumatize anybody
put those eyebrows away Cory nobody
wants to see that nice jugs mom in the
same date night episode Riley's mom
Topanga gets all dressed up for a night
out with Riley's dad Riley's mom is
smoking hot
Riley tells her she looks
Wow Topanga tells Riley she looks Wow to
Ben Riley says she doesn't have the BAM
in the boom and uh and then Riley
surprised us all when pointed to her
mom's rack yep just your normal family
comedy where the teenage daughter
congratulate her mom on her amazing
melons it's nice to compliment your mom
but maybe more along the lines of nice
pot roast mom or Wow mom you drive like
Mario Andretti this compliment ventures
into adult humor territory for sure
Topanga reassures Riley but the reason
she married her father is because he
loves her no matter how she looks but
Cory's face when Topanga walks in shows
it certainly doesn't hurt to have the
BAM and the boom naughty books at the
library when Riley and her boyfriend
Lucas are at the library together they
get schooled by the librarian about
learning to talk to each other they have
only been communicating via text so when
it comes to face-to-face exchanges
they're awkward and speechless the
librarian encourages Riley to read one
of the countless stories in the books on
the shelves about love so she will know
what to say the Lucas Riley tries to
grab a book on the librarians desk but
the librarian snags it out of her hand
and says not that one then Riley tries
to grab a different book on the desk and
the librarian jumps on that one too
implying that this lady has been reading
some pretty inappropriate literature
what's in those books we're pretty sure
this librarians mind is in the gutter
apparently there's good reading material
down there for girls for every boy in
Girl Meets World mr. Matthews takes away
all of the students cell phones to
remind them that they don't need to rely
on technology he wants them to
communicate face-to-face then Farkle
gets up to address the class for what he
calls Farkle time he says that was
something like Farkle and technology he
will be able to clone Riley and her best
friend Maya when Riley mentions that
means that there will be four of them
and one of him he says he thinks that
would be awesome but there's no way this
kid is hinting at what he seems to be
hinting at right what's this kid gonna
do with four girls this joke is totally
adult humor seriously Farkle you are
hilarious and ambitious but why don't we
hold off on the cloning for now let's
wait until you can at least grow some
facial hair check out that touch Riley's
little brother Augie has a girlfriend's
name Ava
although they both still have their baby
teeth the relationship is pretty awesome
they even got married in one episode the
running joke about this relationship is
that they say various old things about
each other some find it cute while
Auggie's mother Topanga is pretty
against the whole thing in Girl Meets
farkles choice Topanga meets Ava's mom
surprise surprise she's a bit full of
herself just like her daughter in this
episode the adult humour hits the next
level when Auggie bends over to pick
something up and Ava says check out that
touch what um you're six years old what
are you doing talking about people's
touches what message is this sending hey
kids objectify your crush and intimate
adult relationships you are far too
young to understand is this funny or
just weird you be the judge reproductive
eggs and girl meets she don't like me
mr. Matthews tries to teach the kids
about reproductive health let's just say
he's not doing so hot mr. Matthews is
clearly horribly uncomfortable talking
about this aspect of the human body with
his pubescent students when smackle asks
if she can help explain the human body
to the class during what she calls
snuggle time mr. Matthews is all too
glad to give her the floor so he can
avoid the subject
smackle goes on to explain very vividly
what she has learned what follows is a
long big gesture bleeped out
presentation with shocks confuses and
4/5 everyone in the classroom check out
mr. Matthews his face this is obviously
a joke meant for adults but those
gestures are hilarious what do you
suppose she is trying to say with those
thumbs these kids got a lot more than
they bargained for in Huff class today
that's for sure WTF that smackle kid has
a real talent for adult humor and funny
innuendos and girl meets the real world
when Isaiah runs in to tell the gang his
cookie came everyone says the phrase
cookie day - which Snapple replies what
the f before Farkle places his hand over
her mouth to keep her from dropping the
f-bomb on a Disney Channel show
whoo whoa dizzy that's super edgy we
love smackle that girl is full of spunk
and suggestive jokes that keep viewers
rolling on the floor laughing we're
still blown away that Disney would let
some of these jokes fly they were
probably blinded by smack Oh
heartwarming charm she's a keeper she
just might need to have her mouth washed
out with soap a couple of times like
they did back in the day
don't worry smackle the taste goes away
after an hour or so bone Appetit
jailbait jokes in girl meets the
telltale tots Maya has a crush on an
older dude who also happens to be
Riley's uncle Maya calls him uncle boy
because she thinks he's so hot she
convinces Briley to sneak out of the
house with her so they can follow Josh
to a college party Josh's friends meet
Riley and Maya and starts checking them
out he even greets them with a flirty
phrase how you do it Maya replies saying
that they are in middle school and the
guy recoils in for what exactly was
going on in this dude's mind that made
him jump back at the thought of these
girls being underage he tells Josh that
the girls can't be in his dorm room
there's not enough room for them with
his enormous shame monster taking up all
the space in their jailbait jokes we did
not expect that from a Disney show
cannibalism and girl meets rules mr.
Matthews walks in on a classroom full of
rowdy students as punishment mr. Matthew
decides to lock the kids in the
classroom for one hour and leave them to
their own devices he says he thinks
within one minute they'll be eating each
other sure enough after one minute Lucas
Maya and Riley corner Farkle talking
about how hungry they are Lucas even
calls Farkle chicken this harkens back
to an old Charlie Chaplin film that came
out right after the Donner Party
incident happened you see during the
gold rush the Donner Party had to resort
to cannibalism in order to survive the
brutal winter while heading west for
gold Charlie Chaplin makes fun of this
in his film the gold rush when his
friend sees him as a giant chicken
definitely a hilarious adult joke and a
tribute to the classic film the
birds and the bees talk and girl meets
first date mr. Matthew sees the sparks
between his daughter Riley and dreamy
hunk Lucas and decides to put a stop to
this budding spring romance so he picked
her up whisked her away and got into a
classroom full of her peers to give her
the birds and bees talk when Riley asked
if he is going to give her the talk in
front of everyone if Maya tells him to
do it so they can see what he knows
that's a pretty adult joke don't you
think then Farkle asks mr. Matthews to
give his daughter to him for four oxen
and his best milking cow right let's
sell underage girls into marriage like
they did in the olden days you know for
livestock a joke as old as time someone
needs to give these guys of feminism
talk paging Gloria Steinem the talk with
mom okay let's see if Riley's mom aka
Topanga is better with the talk that her
dad was in girl meets father
Bradley comes to her mother for some
girl time and that her mom had to know
that this was going to happen her mom
says she knows a lot of things are going
to happen and asks which one it is Riley
says make up and Topanga looks slightly
relieved we wonder what Barry's mom
thought she was going to say whatever it
is it's probably too mature for young
ears then Topanga explains that Riley
can half make up because it leads to
other things what things does make up
lead to Topanga glam rock acne or
perhaps something else were not allowed
to say this conversation is definitely
full of adult jokes
cover your ears kids I'd do something
and girl meets mr. squirrels goes to
Washington the kids learn all about
politics and help a major underdog with
his campaign for the Senate the janitor
Harley rolls on TV into the classroom so
mr. Matthews can teach the students
about the ways of the political world
Harley asks if he can stay for the
lecture when mr. Matthew asks if he's
interested in politics he explains he is
interested in why school budgets are
being cut
he says he's also interested in why they
take away art and music then he drops a
joke that probably went over the younger
audience's head he says that without
music he'd do something we're not
exactly sure what he meant but it seemed
to suggest something pretty dark most
likely too dark for a sweet little
misho and we are pretty sure that we
don't want to find out what that is
battle of the attack whistles so one
minute you're watching a fun Disney show
about kids and teenagers being goofy
in the next minute attack a whistle
battle most kids probably don't know why
women carry around an attack whistle and
we hope they never have to find out this
is a kids show
so hopefully kids watching and think the
whistle Riley blows is from a soccer
coach when she answers the door and sees
her dad's older brother Eric dressed up
like a Rip Van Winkle she freaks out
yells the word stranger and blows her
attack whistle he screams back and blows
his attack whistle this is likely very
confusing for the younger kid OHS
watching usually when they hear a loud
whistle it's because their coach is
telling them to run and hustle when an
attack whistle is blown you're supposed
to well run and hustle hmm maybe this
joke works on many levels
shocker buy the locker when Riley and
Maya get into a big fight because Riley
didn't stick up for her with Lucas they
have it out in the school hallway that's
when we find the biggest adult joke of
them all their friend is a yellow that
the girls are about to have a chick
fight okay kind of sexist but we'll let
that slide but then she tells everyone
to gather around and test he'll charge
them one dollar to see what he calls the
Shocker by the lockers now maybe that
joke is innocent enough but given all
the other adult innuendos we found in
this show we think it's no accident that
they went with this particular turn of
phrase see kids when someone uses the
term shocker
they should be referring to well let's
just say it's very mature a very adult
joke we can't believe they got away with
that one that's it for 15 funniest adult
jokes in girl meets world thanks for
stopping by the things see you next time
[Music]